a former israeli space chief has broken
the news
that extraterrestrials exist our world
leaders have been in contact with them
and the aliens are part of a galactic
federation
which i did not believe until i saw
leaked video
from one of their meetings
[Music]
looks nicer than any sort of meeting at
the u.n or the
european union there is an alien
federation and they are exerting a lot
of influence over us
but that wretched hive of scum and
villainy is a lot closer than mars or
pluto i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from sharon
bisriges who coincidentally just
subscribed to the channel
yesterday right before the show so
welcome to the channel sharon sharon
said
santa claus was a poll worker until they
caught him checking his list
twice this is true this is true then
absolutely not
uh and unfortunately santa claus could
have brought us a lot of votes in
greenland
but unfortunately he checked his list
twice and that was not good
for the fraud that was taking place i
don't know if it took place in the north
pole
certainly we have evidence of
irregularities
all throughout georgia pennsylvania
michigan had some shenanigans very
likely wisconsin
and yet and yet
how do i put this it ain't over until
the fat lady sings
and the fat lady is not singing yet
but she is warming up you don't hear her
singing but you do hear her warming up
we have said from the very beginning
when all those kind of squishy
conservatives wanted us to concede the
election very early
and a lot of other people said
absolutely not this is trump definitely
100
we've said there's obviously evidence of
fraud
and we're not going to concede this
election until the electors vote until
the legal process plays out
the legal process dealt the trump
campaign
a very unfortunate blow yesterday
the probably strongest case at the
supreme court
or that could have gone to the supreme
court was from pennsylvania because
pennsylvania
obviously violated their state
constitution
by permitting widespread unsolicited
mail-in ballots
justice alito decided to move up the day
that they could hear
potentially hear this case to before the
safe harbor deadline before
the pennsylvania would at that point
decide where their electors were going
and they did move that up and then in
one sentence the supreme court
shot down the trump campaign's efforts
they wrote the application for
injunctive relief presented to justice
alito and by him referred to the court
is denied there were no dissents
recorded doesn't mean there weren't
dissents in the room but it means that
there were no dissents recorded here so
this the court is speaking with one
voice because because
regardless of the judicial aspects of
this question
there's the political aspect which is
the court does not want to be seen as
interfering in the election even when it
would be appropriate for them to do so
ted cruz the very fine senator
and very fine podcast co-host a verdict
came out swinging senator cruz was
supposed to
give the oral arguments when this case
was heard at the supreme court
but then the court shot it down so cruz
came out and said he's disappointed in
the court
said that the legal challenge raised
serious and pressing issues about
election integrity
he's absolutely right i'm disappointed
in the court as well
the the supreme court particularly under
john roberts
has wanted to be seen as not interfering
in politics and
as a result ironically the court often
seems very very political because they
seem like they're basing their
decisions to hear cases or not hear
cases of their rulings based
not on the legal facts but on the
political ramifications
i probably would have would have bet you
this from the beginning i mean i could
have told you this early on that the
court was not going to want to
interfere because they don't want to be
blamed one way or the other there's no
good political outcome
for them even if as a judicial matter it
seems
very clear that the election officials
in pennsylvania broke
the constitutional rules there there is
one last court case that could give
president trump a sliver
of hope there was jonathan turley the
law professor came out and he said
it's the landing space for this trump
campaign aircraft is running out and now
turley says you'd have to land a jumbo
jet on a postage stamp
there does remain that sliver of hope
that sliver of hope is from texas
which gives all of us hope very often
texas is now
suing other states georgia pennsylvania
wisconsin and michigan
over their election irregularities
because what they're saying is basically
by these states
screwing up their elections and possibly
rigging
the election in certain places by
violating the law that
disenfranchises texas right because
you're now swinging the whole election
the states don't have any right to do
that
the supreme court would have original
jurisdiction here because it's a state
suing other states but looking at the
way that the supreme court ruled on the
pennsylvania case
which was extraordinarily strong for
trump
very difficult to believe that those
judges are going to grow spines
in the meantime so it's not looking good
i think we should remain hopeful
i often use this line which i borrowed
from a great priest friend of mine which
is that
there are the difference between a
scottish optimist and a scottish
pessimist
is the scottish pessimist says things
can't get any worse the scottish
optimist says oh yes they can
and optimism and pessimism are kind of
two sides of the same coin they're just
these feelings that you feel all the
time
and we don't have that we we have hope
uh but that
it plays into a little bit of this idea
of the optimism and pessimism in that
we have hope hope is a fact right we
have hope in our salvation
one day but we know things are going to
get a lot worse in the meantime if biden
does become president
which now appears likely then
we are in for it folks not because of
the galactic federation
from pluto that the former israeli space
chief is talking about
but because of foreign powers right here
on earth
china is going to exert an incredible
amount of influence
they already are they're actually
already bragging about it if it turns
out this way if the trump legal team
is not able to overcome all of the
nefarious powers allayed against them
look a lot will have been accomplished
within four years i hope more can be
accomplished in the future
we will have to be grateful for the
memories and when you want to preserve
your memories you got to check out
legacy box legacy box is a safe
and affordable way to digitally preserve
all your home movies and photos
that are currently trapped on dated
formats like vhs or film
with everything going on here is a great
way
to ensure that the focus remains on your
family
this holiday season i'll tell you the
thing about legacy box it's so easy
you get all your old stuff the tapes and
the pictures and all that
and you just put them into little
envelopes you put the stickers on that
they tell you to put on you send it into
them that's it you don't need to think
about it again they digitize it for you
they return
your physical material and the digital
stuff
a beloved family member of mine died i
lost all the photos fortunately i found
some
some more photos from another relative
we got them digitized with legacy bucks
they're great you get it on the cloud on
a thumb drive on a dvd
all sent along a wonderful way to
restore and protect your most
cherished family memories this is the
best deal of the year go to
legacybox.com slash knowles scanner wles
to take advantage of this limited time
offer get 60 off
that offer will not last long so order
the kit now perfect
perfect christmas gift send it out
whenever you're ready it's a sale to
remember go to legacybox.com knowles
and save 60 while supplies last
this is something that should have us
all holding out hope until the very very
last minute
that president trump can somehow eke out
an election victory here i don't i still
don't think there's any reason to
concede before the electors vote
we should all be holding out hope
because it's not just joe biden though
he's probably the greatest example of
this
for decades elite politicians in this
country
have sold us out to china they've done
it because they have a stupid political
ideology
that tells them that rising china is
good for the world that's why they let
the china into the world trade
organization 20 years ago it's why
they've allowed china to steal our
intellectual property that's why they've
allowed china
to violate world trade organization
treaties that's why they've allowed
china to illegally subsidize their steel
and aluminum and
manipulate their currency the list goes
on and on and on and on
most importantly they've allowed china
to steal our jobs
and the the argument for it is oh it's
good for the world if china
gets more economic power they'll
liberalize their country they'll become
more democratic they'll become more like
america and that'll be good for
everybody
obviously that hasn't happened the other
reason is that china china's just buying
direct influence
you you saw this with the hunter biden
scandal you've seen this with other
american politicians
we now have experts on communist china
admitting
this kind of influence there's a
recently recorded lecture
showing a chinese communist party expert
explaining
how china has quote people at the top of
america's core
inner circle this video has been leaked
made its way
onto the internet and into the united
states after it was
censored in china the person giving this
lecture is d
dong shing he's vice dean of the school
of international relations at remnan
iren mean university my chinese is not
great but my ability to read subtitles
is take a listen to this
we know that the trump administration is
in a trade with us
so why can't we fix the trump
administration no
like a couple do with their quarrels we
fixed everything in two months what's
the reason
i'm going to throw out something a
little explosive here it's
just because we have people at the top
at the top of america's core inner
circle of power and influence
we know which people he's talking about
here notably he's talking about
biden who's given speeches about this
he's given speeches about how great it
is
to empower china he's gone on the record
but you've heard all the other kind of
liberal establishment people talking
about this as well this sort of
admission
is so explosive that i didn't believe it
actually this video
was going all around the internet
yesterday i didn't believe it
but mainstream news outlets not many of
them but some of them
are are reporting on this because they
have to because this is real
this this is a real guy he really is the
vice dean of this
ir school and he's really talking about
influence chinese influence in the
united states hostile powers have often
exerted influence in the united states
right now i'm reading witness by
whitaker chambers it's one of the books
that
turned reagan from a liberal into a
conservative it's from an ex-communist
who details in painstaking detail all
of the soviet influence in the united
states during the 30s
during even even a little before that
and during the 40s
guys who were at the very tippy top guys
who were helping to establish the united
nations
guys who were in the state department
guys who were in the justice department
who were communist
spies and they had that soviet union had
that for a long time when people
make fun of mccarthyism where they make
fun of the house on american activities
committee
we all that's like the punch line now
for a lot of people what that fails to
acknowledge
is these guys were right i mean joe
mccarthy was a little bit of a flawed
individual in the way that he carried
these things out no question about it
william f buckley jr founder of national
review wrote one of his first books
defending joe mccarthy because the
central thesis here that the soviet
union had
communist spies at high levels of the
government was obviously true
we know this we know their names we know
the name alger hiss
we know we know people who were
whitaker chambers called this out
mccarthy i suppose called this out nixon
called this out
all made fun of all mocked all have been
sort of written out of the
history of that era but it happened and
it's happening now
with china he goes on
now that we're seeing biden was elected
the traditional elite the political
elite establishment
there are a lot of deals in all these
who helped hunter biden build the
foundation who do you think
who do you think china
this this guy points out very astutely
that wall street
used to exert a lot of influence in the
united states and then after the
financial crisis 2007 2008 wall street
lost a fair bit of their influence and
they were sort of the bad guys because
they plunged us all into this global
recession
still the establishment was playing
along and then you had trump
and trump comes in and he offered a
radically different
policy at the domestic level but also at
the international level
don't forget from bush one maybe even
further back than bush one but certainly
from bush one clinton
bush ii obama the president's changed
the parties changed but the foreign
policy
more or less stayed the same didn't
change all that much
our attitude toward china didn't change
at all really
it kept getting nicer and nicer and
softer and softer
then trump comes in and he says no what
are you guys doing
people make this mistake they think
trump was elected because
of his personality because he said some
mean things and made fun of mika
brzezinski's face
not so donald trump offered a different
policy agenda than did the other
republicans in the primary and then did
joe uh hillary clinton and i suppose joe
biden too
it was a different agenda specifically
with regard to our greatest
geo-political foe
this will be coming back if joe biden
becomes
the president okay this is going to
raise a lot of security issues when we
think about national security we're
always talking about the middle east or
you know terrorists coming over here
a far greater security issue will come
from china there is
no reason to play nicely with china
china views us
as an enemy and an adversary and there
is a political elite in the united
states now
led by joe biden that wants to deny
that adversarial relationship got to
keep security on our mind
and you know when you have personal
security on your mind ring has
everything you need to keep an eye on
your home
this holiday season see and speak to
whoever is at your door from anywhere
with video doorbells
keep an eye on every corner of your
house with easy to install indoor
and outdoor cameras help protect your
whole home with ring
alarm a powerful affordable whole home
security system you can easily
install yourself i travel a bit you know
i i'm i'm happy that sweet little lisa
knows her way around a firearm but i
don't want to rely on that
it's very nice especially now that i
have a nice house you know and
in the sweet era of freedom in tennessee
i'm no longer in my little shoebox in la
it's nice that sweet little lisa will be
able to see who is at the door
before she opens that door it's nice for
me too not
only because of the robbers or the
burglars or also because sometimes you
have unwanted family members come visit
you your mother-in-law i don't know
for a limited time go to ring.com
knowles k-w-l-e
you will get lots of special holiday
offers this is also makes a great gift
one of the reasons it makes a great gift
is because it's not very expensive so
i've given this gift out as friends of
mine
as housewarming presents great christmas
gift as well go to ring.com
knowles canada w-l-e-s
you don't need to just take this
lecturer's word for it we now know
about a chinese spy program that was
going on in the united states that
infiltrated very high levels of
government and that specifically
infiltrated the democratic
party and it infiltrated
actually this was a bigger risk because
one of the people
that this chinese spy christine fang
targeted
and and infiltrated was eric swalwell
and apparently this woman is accused not
just of
raising lots of money for these people
getting in their circles she even slept
with some of these elected politicians
now we're not sure if she slept with
swalwell but you'll remember during eric
swalwell's brief presidential campaign
he
said that he is us i am you that was one
of his slogans
which means that i may have slept with a
chinese spy
which means i'm going to have a lot of
answering to do to sweet little alisa
except that
it means sweet little alisa will also
have slept with the chinese spy
so frankly i don't this is raising a lot
of questions and a lot of feelings and
emotions that i don't want to get into
this is a family program
but in any case that is the allegation
here
christine feng targeted up and coming
local politicians in the bay area
and across the country who had the
potential to make it big on the national
stage
so you know we can make fun of eric swo
all we want and i think it's a fun thing
to do but the guy did make it to
congress which is kind of low level for
the federal
government but still made it to congress
it's a national position
and he was a briefly at least a
presidential candidate so hey that's
something he's a young guy
he's kind of a joke and a goofball but
hey anyway he made it pretty far
and this woman targeted him when he was
very very local
she just saw that there was some promise
here she did this to other
politicians but first of all well she
raised money there was networking
and there is an open question as to
whether or not there was
a more intimate relationship
for her sake i have to hope she didn't
didn't have to talk about making a
sacrifice for your country
talk about taking a difficult job if
your job requires you to jump in in the
sheets with eric swalwell
but this sort of stuff happens when it
became clear that
she was exerting some influence the
intelligence agencies in the united
states
approached swalwell and said hey listen
this lady looks like she's a spy
he did cut out cut off relationships
with her
other politicians appear to as well when
she realized she was being surveilled by
the united states
she hightailed it back to china so it's
pretty clear that she was a spy
there are other chinese spies in the
united states that's we all spy on each
other all
all the governments of the world spy on
one another the question is how
successful are they
and beyond espionage what kind of
influence are they exerting
i'm sure the united states has spies all
over the world but what kind of
influence do they have behind the scenes
certainly some we know china's exerting
a lot of influence
as well one place they exert a lot of
influence is u.s universities
china has made a concerted effort to
influence american universities they've
used different kinds of programs
confucius program other
other different programs as well the
thing about the universities though
is that foreign communists don't don't
need to do very much
to transform them because domestic
communists have done that
perfectly well themselves something very
troubling and defensive has come out of
the
university of maryland school of public
policy and the thing that's troubling
and offensive there is that they're
instructing their instructors that there
should be no troubling or offensive
content in the classroom
this from a letter that was sent out
to faculty members at the umd school of
public policy
told them to add a statement to their
syllabus
promising to commit to diversity while
avoiding
anything that is quote troubling or
causes offense to students
what happens if that letter is troubling
and causes offense to me as a
conservatives as someone who defends
liberal education as somebody who
defends reading the great books which
are
troubling and cause offense very often
that's how they
educate you what happens then something
tells me the school of public policy
won't care because they don't care if
they offend or trouble conservative
students
this is only in one direction and it's
in the direction of political
correctness
which is the orthodoxy and the standard
of leftism or woke-ism or use whatever
words you like
but it's been creeping for decades and
decades through a concerted campaign in
the united states
and it is winning and especially in the
educational
institutions how do we respond to this
sort of thing
i think the old conservative model the
model that
prevailed for i don't know the 1990s and
2000s or early 20 teens
was well what can we do we have to throw
up our hands we couldn't possibly use
politics to fix this problem because
politics that's just the government and
we would never want to use the
government or actually exert the
political power that people give us
so well it's too bad but we'll just have
to fight them
and start our own state universities
so you know if we just start our own
massive state university
then we can influence the culture and i
think that's kind of weak sauce guys
i think the way we fix this is that when
we have the levers of political power
we defund the university of maryland
unless they cut out the nonsense unless
they
change their educational standards which
are currently
bad to be good educational standards
now you can't defund the whole the
school is obviously funded by maryland
if i were governor of maryland i would
defund the school
there they the school also gets federal
funding if i were president of the
united states i would defund the school
until they brought their syllabus in
line with proper
education and away from
politically correct liberal leftist
education
we talked about this a little bit
yesterday all education is coercive all
education
indoctrinates right they're essentially
the same word
so the question is what are you
indoctrinating them
to use the bad word or what are you
educating them in you can't
teach someone how to think without
teaching them what to think and this
sort of thing
is absolute poison to liberal education
and this sort of thing is absolute
poison to a free citizenry we cannot
permit
universities to teach this and the way
to stop that
is not just by writing op-eds the way to
stop that is not just by starting your
own university it's by defunding
and exerting political pressure on these
universities and believe it or not
umd is not even the craziest university
around today
for that you you can't look to the state
universities you have to look
to the wonderful lofty ivy league
where the craziness has somehow
surpassed
just about every other university in the
country we will turn
to cornell in a second but first you
know what time it is it's time to talk
about
movement watches i love movement watches
they've been with this show
since the very beginning 2020 is not
played out by the usual rules
obviously that's going for christmas
shopping as well
a lot of shipping delays a lot of people
are not shopping in stores right now a
lot of stores
are actually not allowing in-person
shopping not a lot of great options but
our friends over at
movement watches have made gift giving
easy movement makes clean modern watches
eyewear and blue light glasses which i
would highly recommend
jewelry as well that look really really
nice and they don't
break the bank their watches feel like a
four or five hundred dollar watch that's
what you'd pay in a department store
but you pay a fraction of the price for
movement they're durable they're high
quality
i've never had to replace the battery in
my movement watches i mean i've had them
now for quite a long time
i've never had scratches or dings on
they just they look really nice they
function very well
movement has this super sleek matte
black packaging it just looks really
cool
i gave my father and my uh stepmother a
movement watch last year and they loved
them this was the biggest hit of the
holiday season
i paid more for other presents but they
didn't care about those presents they
just like the move and watch
get 15 off today with fast free shipping
and free returns by going to mvmt.com
knowles k w l e s mvmt.com
knowles you and your friends and
relatives will thank me
cornell university has gone even woker
than the trigger warnings and taking
offensive books off the syllabus cornell
university
wants its students to get a flu
vaccination not the wu flu but the
regular flu
and i everyone's so crazy about public
public health these days that they're
they want all their students to get a
flu
shot however they are going to exempt
certain students from the flu
vaccination
if those students are black
no i'm not making this up if you're a
white
student at cornell and you're on campus
and you're residing there you need to
get the flu vaccine
if you are a black student you don't
need to get the flu vaccine
and so this raises some problems because
i don't get the flu shot and i don't
know that i've ever gotten a flu shot
and i don't intend to this year either
but because i'm a young healthy person
and so my risk is low i guess there's
there is a risk you know there's a risk
to it but
i'm willing to take that risk
there are two there's a contradiction
here right if you believe
that the vaccines are really really
really really good for you
and the flu shot is really really really
good for you
and you say only the white people need
to get it who cares if the black people
get it you sound kind of
racist right right right but now but
then if you're saying that white people
have to get the vaccine
and black people don't have to get the
vaccine because the because these sorts
of
vaccines and public health measures have
been really horrible and terrible to
black people over the years
then you're saying that the vaccines
maybe aren't so great you're
undercutting your argument on the facts
either you have to undercut your
argument on race or you have to undercut
your argument
on the vaccines cornell though in the
lofty ivy league
uh they they don't understand that very
simple
issue historical
injustices and current events will allow
black students to avoid getting the flu
shot
and and they're they're referring not
just by the way to
you know scientific experiments that
were undertaken on black people
in various places in the past they're
referring to
the blm argument they're referring to
police brutality
you know or the killing of whoever's you
know
the the idea that there's a scourge and
an epidemic
of racist cops killing innocent black
men all around the country
which obviously is not happening but
they're referring to that what does that
have to do with the flu shot
it shows you that the just
trust the science people don't
understand anything about politics
the word science when it is invoked in a
political context
does not refer to the scientific method
of material inquiry or
science in its broader sense knowledge
it's referring specifically to political
knowledge political agendas and i know
that there are some
conservatives i'm not i'm not even
talking about the leftists here
who are totally bought into the
scientific agenda and have been for 150
years
because they view their political agenda
as science itself
so it's illegitimate to dispute it or to
push against it
right the science of politics the
science of history so i'm just talking
to the conservatives there are some
conservatives who say look i don't want
these political battles
over the masks or vaccines or whatever
you know
they they're a little more open to the
masks or these kind of public health
measures they're more willing to listen
to fauci
say look i just i just want to follow
the science i don't want the science to
be
clouded by politics that
is not possible it's not possible
public health refers to science in part
and it refers to politics
the word public is synonymous with
political they refer to the exact same
thing
when we're talking about public health
we're talking about politics
and all of science
the most hard-nosed scientist who says i
just follow
the empirical facts on the ground even
he
will be forced to acquiesce to
politically correct standards
you can't escape no society and no
segment of society can escape
that society's standards and i don't
care how materialist and
and scientific you want to pretend that
you are they won't escape it either
just look at abortion it's very clear
that unborn babies are babies it's
they're obviously human they're
obviously alive they're obviously
babies but it's not politically correct
to say that
and so scientists concoct all sorts of
ways to deny that they're babies because
they have to because the standards make
them
consider gender theory it's very clear
that men are men and women are women and
men cannot become women and women cannot
become men
and men who put on dresses and lipstick
are not magically all of a sudden women
that's very clear there's a scientific
matter it's obviously clear
and yet there are many scientists who
refuse to say this
not just quack scientists there are
plenty of those but broadly speaking it
is politically incorrect and so they
won't do it
when scientists remember larry summers
got fired as the president of harvard
because he suggested that the reason
that that women
do not excel at the very very highest
levels of
math is because of just a little
investigation he'd done
to suggest that the bar curve for for
men in terms of
aptitude is broader than women meaning
that the
dumbest people on earth and the smartest
people we're talking very small numbers
of people
would be more likely to be men rather
than women and he's just presented this
as one
explanation of this fact that
in the hard sciences and in mathematics
there are more men who
focus on it than women he lost his job
for that
the science any kind social science hard
science physical science
it will acquiesce eventually to the
politically correct standard
and that's what's happening with the flu
shot at cornell and that's what's going
to happen
with the public debate over the vaccine
roll out it's what's going to happen
that's what's already been happening
obviously with the masks and i think
that we need to
very often conservatives want to say hey
i'm i follow the real science
i'm not like a leftist who follows the
fake science on gender and stuff i
follow the real science
don't don't even do that stop using the
word science in that way science refers
to knowledge
and it's very important that we educate
ourselves and pursue
inquiry in the material realm in the
metaphysical realm in
in all of these sorts of things i i love
that i love education i love
reading i love scientific investigation
but but the way that term is used is
politicized and we should not follow
scientists we should not be ruled by
scientists
we should not pretend that science is
outside of the political realm when we
talk about it publicly
we need political solutions to these
things if if you're in politics you need
political solutions and you can't put
your head in the sand and pretend
that certain aspects of politics are not
political
and by the way the way you can exert
influence over places like cornell
is defund the school this listen to the
statement due to long-standing systemic
racism and health inequities in this
country
individuals from some marginalized
communities may have concerns about
needing to agree to
the flu shot historically the bodies of
black indigenous and other
people of color have been mistreated the
bodies not their souls the souls have
been treated fine but the bodies haven't
and used by people in power for profit
or gain what
insanity this is defund cornell defund
it
stop giving them federal money well now
it's going to be difficult if joe biden
becomes the president
which it increasingly would appear that
he will but when we do have the levers
of power
use them use them defund this craziness
there's no neutral playing ground here
folks and the left understands that and
smart conservatives understand that as
well
and by the way smart democrats don't
even believe the nonsense they're
spatting we caught some more left-wing
politicians violating their own orders
which does fill my cup with leftist
years as a slight consolation to the
madness around us
speaking of the leftist steers have you
noticed this is a new life to steers
tumbler it's new and improved
it is dishwasher safe looks very cool
just in time to enjoy the salty tears
while watching all of our new content
the prageru library coming here
including my show at prageru the book
club candace owens coming to the daily
wire getting her own show next year a
lot of great stuff the daily wire
christmas ornament which you can get
right now
you can get all the daily wire hosts
plus jeremy boring is santa's adorable
elves
made of painted metal today is the last
day to get it text christmas
to h3400 text christmas to 83
400 to get yours we'll be right back
with a lot more
is chicago alderman a city council
member in chicago very crooked
left-wing democratic city he's in
trouble
because he violated his own lockdown
orders you see chicago illinois
under certain lockdown restrictions but
alderman tom tunney
from the 44th ward of chicago a democrat
of course
has been opening a restaurant that he
owns the ann
sather restaurant a breakfast restaurant
in chicago's lakeview neighborhood
he's been opening his restaurant on the
sly
to try to keep the restaurant open i
actually have great great
sympathy for tony i know friends of mine
who have restaurants and who have bars
who are opening them secretly they're
actual speakeasies for the past 10 years
or so there's been this trend in bars
to have fake speakeasies so there's some
kind of kitschy way to walk in you need
to know password
but they're all legal now we have real
species and i've gone to several of them
and it's been very enjoyable
i know a number of police officers
actually have gone to many of them
because the police officers think that
the politicians who make these stupid
rules are out of their minds
i don't blame the cops for going into
those places i don't blame the patrons
for going into those places i don't
blame the business owners for keeping
those places open
unless those business owners are the
politicians pushing the rules
i do blame those guys and maybe tom
tunney
believes that these rules are bogus if
he believes that and he doesn't want to
enforce them
at his own place of business he should
resign from the board of aldermen
but something tells me he's not going to
do that none of these politicians
none none of the prominent politicians
pushing the mask orders
or the lockdowns or the closures none of
them believe this stuff they don't fear
the virus
they don't think they're going to die
from coronavirus and
they don't think that there's any risk
in going and eating out a lot of them go
and do that anyway
california my former state
california assembly members are
violating their own social distancing
rules so
on november 25th california issued new
guidelines about the virus
said don't plan celebrations with
multiple households
it is safest to celebrate the holidays
with people who already live with you
but if you invite others only invite a
maximum of two other households to your
gathering okay fine
then on monday california state assembly
members
switched the location of their
swearing-in session from the state
capitol to the golden one
center because they were so afraid of
social distancing this has not changed
since november 25th even on monday
they were so afraid they go to this big
arena because the capital wasn't big
enough to swear in the new members
and then right after that swearing-in
ceremony five members of the california
assembly
met up and went to grab a bite to eat at
a restaurant
and they were not so spread out as they
were in the
the arena they were not so spread out as
they were would have been in the state
capitol they were sitting at a table
together
and i bet you bottom dollar they weren't
wearing masks
because they don't believe it because i
don't believe it either
i don't believe it either i don't think
that it is
essential to the public health that we
shut down all the restaurants i don't
think it is essential to the public
health
that we cancel thanksgiving or christmas
i think it's
completely bogus those orders
i don't think it's essential to the
public health that we wear a mask all
the time everywhere you know that filthy
cloth mask
that very few people wash or wear
properly and they're always touching
their face when they put it on
i don't think that's going to save the
country don't think it
is very important at all by the way
there was one independent in that group
of of assemblymen four democrats
no surprise whatsoever and yet the
insanity
continues usa today has
an op-ed that i thought was satirical
kovid has turned breathing into a deadly
event
and all of us into potential serial
killers
that has to be satirical right it's not
if i hold my breath when i hug my
parents
will that spare me the greek tragedy of
killing them this mental toll will last
long after the threat fades there is a
mental toll here
and there is a a true epidemic
that is psychological it's hysterics
like this man
michael stern absolute hysterics
afraid of the flu a very strong flu a
coronavirus
i guess to be specific a very strong one
i'm not i'm not downplaying that it's
strong and that that
especially people in certain groups are
at risk for it
it's got a far greater than 99 survival
rate
people are referring to it as a plague
he refers to it as a plague it ain't the
plague
it's a virulent virus that has been with
us
now for a long time and it's going to be
with us for a very long time and we were
told millions and millions of people
were going to die from it and thankfully
that turned out not to be true
this guy really believes that we're all
serial killers this is the political
problem by the way
which is that we are social creatures we
live in a body politic we need to
interact with one another we are not
meant to be alone there are a lot of
people who are dying right now alone in
nursing homes
dying of loneliness dying because
they've lost the will to live
because these psycho politicians and
hysterical opinion columnists
have made it such that we no longer view
our loved ones and our fellow citizens
as friends and loved ones we view them
as bags of germs who are out to kill us
and we're out to kill them
that is a far greater threat to the
public health and to society
than any virus could be and certainly
certainly then this virus under a
potential joe biden administration
public health is going to be used to
justify all
sorts of madness biden ran as a kind of
moderate you
remember that's
out you can just see from the people
he's already naming to his presumptive
cabinet
he's naming radical people and he's
empowering radical voices
here's one voice elise hogue who's the
president of naral the abortion
the main abortion group she says that
the height amendment
which prohibits taxpayer funding from
going to abortion is a discriminatory
policy passed specifically to limit the
freedom of low-income women
and women of color it must go hashtag be
bold and hyde
joe biden supported the height amendment
and prohibiting taxpayer funding for
abortion for his whole career but then
he licked his index finger put it up so
the wins changed now he supports
taxpayer-funded abortion
and it by the way it was always a little
bit of a force because money is fungible
so
you know you give your tax money to the
government you can't say this dollar
goes here and this dollar goes there but
still hypocrisy is the tribute advice
based to virtue
at the very least we had this principle
in the country that taxpayers should not
be forced to fund the wholesale
slaughter of infants
now that's gone and there there is an
irony too to this woman elise hogue
because listen what she said she says
the height amendment's discriminatory
it's
to limit the freedom of low-income women
and women of color it must go
what that means is that elise hogue
thinks that
there are too many poor black women
having babies
and we now need every taxpayer in the
united states
to pay to kill those
babies of poor black women so that there
aren't too many of them
that is her explicit argument
i'm not twisting her words i'm not
unfairly adding in something that she's
not saying she's saying
not enough poor black women are getting
abortions
too many poor black women are having
babies and we need to make sure
that we can kill more of those babies
it would be discriminatory other it is
it is discriminatory there's no
ain't no question about that
even the journalists are getting in on
this science racket gotta reform
journalism too should
use our political discourse to reform
journalism steve cole
of the new yorker was was specifically
was discussing mark zuckerberg and
facebook and how
facebook is permitting conservatives to
speak sometimes
so that you know that's really bad and
and so he's defending free speech and
he's saying free speech is being used
now ironically against
journalism and he's talking about how
journalists are the defenders of free
speech
but he gets a phrase in there that
is very unsettling and it gives you a
glimpse of what our future politics is
going to look like
those of us in journalism have to come
to terms with the fact that
free speech a principle that we hold
sacred is being weaponized against
the principles of journalism and what do
we do about that
i just say you know as as reporters we
kind of march into this war with
our facts uh nobly shouldered as if
they were going to win the day and what
we're seeing is that
because of the scale of this alternate
reality that you've been talking about
our facts our principles our scientific
method
it isn't enough so what do we do
our scientific method hold on you're
telling me hack
journalists follow a scientific method
the new yorker and msnbc are now
scientists
no they're not but it shows you that the
word science when invoked in politics
is a deceptive slogan and euphemism and
you should the minute someone brings up
science
in politics you should immediately just
turn your ears off
or at least know maybe you listen to
them but you at least know
that they are attempting to deceive you
or maybe they've been deceived
themselves i'm not even going to get
into the idea that
msnbc and the new yorker are the great
defenders of free speech and the jury
the mainstream journalists are our
wonderful defenders i'm not even going
to touch that
i just want to point out how
preposterous the scientific argument
is here because there there is something
politically we should do about this
you know there was another good article
i read in the new york times i can't
believe i'm saying this
this is a week to be surprised folks
we've discovered that we have aliens
running the galaxy
and have a federation and we also
discover that the new york times
occasionally publishes something
worthwhile
new york times joe from scranton didn't
win back the working
class now
i'll leave aside for a moment the
question of whether or not joe biden
really got all those votes that people
say that he got whether or not he really
got all those votes they say he got in
philadelphia
and atlanta and detroit i'm a little
skeptical that he he really won all
those
votes however if the electors give the
election to joe biden which the supreme
court seems to have given them
the free way to do he will be the pride
just by definition he'll be the
president
and he will not have been elected
even even if you do take all the counts
at face value he will not have been
elected by the working class
the new york times and their analysis
shows
for years democrats have preached the
gospel of changing demographics
as the country grew more diverse they
argued the electorate would inevitably
tilt
in their favor and give their party an
unbeatable edge well the country is more
racially diverse than ever before
but exit polls suggest that joe biden
lost ground among latino black and asian
american voters in 2020
compared with hillary clinton's
performance in 2016.
demographics it turns out are not
political destiny but diplomas
just might be the clearest way to
understand the results of the 2020
election and perhaps the shifting state
of our politics is through the education
voting gap
voters with college degrees flocked to
mr biden emerging as the crucial voting
bloc in the suburbs
those without them continued their their
flight from the democratic party so
we've heard about this for a while now
the point that the new york times wants
to make is that
the people with these college degrees
are much more educated than all those
people without the college degrees and
that's just preposterous
it's preposterous because the
the college degrees don't reflect what
they once did the college degrees used
to be a credential
and so or
i'm sorry the college degrees now are a
credential they used to
signify that you had an education
in the past i don't know say 20 years
including while i was in school well
people in my generation were in school
especially for really top schools it
became much harder to get
into the school than it was to graduate
from the school
why because the education itself wasn't
all that rigorous but it still had the
cachet
of if you go to this special school then
you'll have this on your resume and
you'll get a good job and make a lot of
money and so being much harder to get in
than it was to get out to graduate
this is true in all of the fields but
you know i'm a defender of the liberal
arts and liberal education
it even that you're not getting
the classical education the great books
learning the
way to make sense of your freedom that
you once were and so even on that front
for i don't think education should be
primarily
geared toward getting a job or making a
lot of money or something i think it
should be
toward making sense of your culture
knowing your culture cultivating your
own self as a free person
even on that front the colleges are
failing what they are doing is churning
out leftists
because they are just working in a very
shallow ideological way and they're
replacing great books
and great disciplines with
ideological shallow political
programming
what's the answer to that defund it
defund it this
this edifice this galactic federation
this galactic federation
that i'm worried about is the
establishment that goes from beijing all
the way to the biden household
that includes the mainstream media that
includes higher education
that includes lower education very often
that includes corporate america they've
all bought into that establishment
you can hear the ccp experts joking
about it they say yeah trump was not the
establishment
but don't worry the establishment's
coming back we must exercise
as much as we can political power to
defund that
if the new york times is right the
demographics may not be destiny in the
sense that immigration may not be
the single issue it's a very important
issue still
but higher education could be a major
major issue
if we throw up our hands if we refuse to
have the confidence and courage
to exhibit the strength to stop that
we have no one to blame for our losses
in the future but ourselves i'm michael
knowles this is michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there